when I was in high school I went to live
with this family and had a re at the
edge of the neighborhood they had a
fancy little uh sandwich and liquor shop
called Dakota's wine and
feed and they had dude they had all type
of cheeses in there they had
gr they had damn um sa sier you know
they had that booah base they had all
kind of [__] [__] French
[__] I mean let's be honest stuff that's
fancy is
French that boo you Bas bro that Bri
that that
G and these are mostly before that all
the if I ever even heard a word one of
these words it was usually like kind of
a middle name of like a black friend of
mine you know oh that's [__] Jerry G
Jackson right there you know oh that's
Shanti sh
Bri uh Crandle you know so this before
that that's all it was but now here and
they had these different types of meats
man Prato they had
um what else I don't even know [__]
lamb I didn't even know people was
trying to eat lambs dude where I'm from
you would never eat a lamb if you saw a
lamb you'd pet it or look at it while
you're trying to go to
sleep and then you get over into these
fancier areas and these [__] are
eating Lambs
dude first of all lamb uh number one
animal in the Bible how about that maybe
don't eat
it maybe don't eat lamb just for the
soulle thought that you know they say
the Lamb of
God maybe God's trying to drop you a h n
t on what not to hu n t you feel me
don't kill
lambs and then you go to these fancy
neighborhoods and they eat you know they
got them lamb scy Alan and [__] you
see some rich dude he's driving a
Corvette and he's just throwing chunks
of lamb in the air and his little son
little fontleroy a fifth he's catching
them in his jaw and they out here eating
the eating the damn just [__] just
nibble snacking on the Lord doing 45
miles an hour in a school zone and
probably wearing shoes made out of damn
chocolot and that's who they are boy
rich
people so anyway I would work in there
and I would save these pieces of I would
save up all the nice stuff off of those
the things that rich people didn't eat I
would save it on one plate and at the
end of the night I would make me a big
ass sandwich bro one huge Rich hitter
dude and i' put the the washing machine
down for the last time that you know you
close it with the handle and they got
all the dishes in there and it's and you
could the steam just this just heat
coming off that [__] just I mean
moisturizing your skin I look like about
a dam damn 9mon old just standing there
just the heat off of that thing and you
could hear the cups and the glasses and
the last salad dish bowls and the ladles
everything all just getting cuz I'd pack
that [__] full of dishes you're
supposed to put nine dishes dishes in
that in in that uh in that thing and I
put 78 dishes in that [__] and four
spoons and that heat was just coming off
and I was just and I'd pick up that big
huge
sandwich bro and just take a bite of
that thing and say one day I'm going
have me
something
nice I used to do
that